all of the cells in our body require a
constant healthy stream of oxygen-rich
blood but risk factors like smoking
aging and a poor diet can cause severe
problems in our arteries they can become
clogged up with sticky plaques made of
fat cholesterol and other nasty deposits
this causes the arteries to harden and
narrow reducing the blood flow and
starving the limbs of oxygenated blood
doctors call severe cases critical limb
ischemia and it killed half of its
victims within five years the worst
affected areas are usually the toes and
feet and it isn't pretty
it can cause burning pain skin ulcers
and gangrene confining people to their
beds the standard treatment is surgery
to remove the blockage using lasers or
cutters to destroy the deposits or
miniature balloons to expand the
narrowed arteries or bypass surgery to
give the blood a different route around
the blockage but some blockages occur in
hard-to-reach places or the patient is
just too unwell for an invasive
procedure in fact almost 1/3 of
sufferers of critical limb ischemia have
no options for treatment and most of
those patients end up needing to have
their limb amputated but there could be
another way
new research might be able to restore
the supply of blood to deprived limbs by
encouraging new blood vessels to grow
the first is gene therapy by inserting
genes that promote blood vessel growth
into a virus and delivering this to the
cells that form the inner walls of the
arteries researchers hope to stimulate
new blood vessels to grow around the
blockage and into the oxygen-starved
sites although this therapy has helped
wound healing it hasn't yet reduced the
time between CLI diagnosis and
amputation in clinical trials a more
promising option is to extract special
cells from the patient's bone marrow or
peripheral blood and inject these into
the affected areas amongst these cells
are the immature blood vessel cells
called endothelial progenitor cells or
epcs
researchers hope that these cells will
migrate to down
tissues and blockages and trigger the
growth of new blood vessels early
clinical trials have shown cell
therapies like this to be safe and
effective for wound healing but have not
yet reduced the likelihood of amputation
to get better results researchers are
trying to increase the concentration of
epcs doing this in early trials has
reduced pain and increase the distance
that patients can walk if doctors can
regrow the blood vessels and revitalize
blood stuff tissues and they might just
be able to save a patient's life and
limb
you